posez lui vos questions on vous trouve
l'info j'aimerais savoir ce que les
marchands avec les papillons période les
ventes d'un nouveau madame lamy espère
que les détaillants ne nous refile pas
en douce il est maintenant retourné par
les autres consommateurs
on a généralement 90 jours pour
retourner en classe ça peut aller
jusqu'à 120 jours même un an au pays le
taux de retour des matelas varie entre 2
10 6%
nous avons contacté plusieurs
détaillants la plupart d'entre eux ne
les revendent pas ils les donnent les
détruisent ou les recycle toutefois
certaines chaînes en revendre
selon la loi fédérale hall matelas ne
doit pas représenter de danger pour la
santé humaine
ouais on espère les détaillants eux nous
disent qu'il en va de leur réputation
les matelas retourner sont inspectés et
nettoyés à la vapeur
mais au-delà de ça roenick on n'a pas le
droit de couvrir que matelas neuf
s'il a servi
en plus le québec exige que les
maintenant retourner soit identifié avec
une étiquette jaune comme ceci bref vous
filer en douce un matelas retourner ça
ne respecte pas la loi passée le monde